[Musique]
il a dû être mis en ligne ce qui était
un très simple et puis évidemment le
public en d'énormément mais finalement
l' avantage c'est que ça permet de
toucher un public plus large puisque des
personnes qui n'habitent pas 50 ans
enfin qui sont éloignés qui ne seraient
pas venues peut tout à fait voir toutes
les rencontres les spectacles en différé
jusqu'au 30 juin
et puis j'ai ça m'a amené aussi à créer
une proposition nouvelle des podcasts
[Musique]
demain à 18 heures une rencontre avec
cécile oumhani romancière peau est
vraiment un travail très intéressant
on a tellement besoin de garder quand
même ce lien avec le public et puis de
soutenir les artistes parce que pour eux
bah on entend dans les nouvelles c'est
vraiment extrêmement compliqué ça permet
quand même de faire des choses